THIS IS THE MARCH ELEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY MEETING OF THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE I WE DO
NOT HAVE ENOUGH NUMBERS AT THIS
MOMENT TO ESTABLISH QUORUMS ASK
CIVIC AND THE- SUBCOMMITTEE ON.
END WITHOUT A- ITEM I KNOW A
MISTER CHEN WAS HERE FIRST BUT
HE IS ALLOWED MS RIVAS 2% FIRST
NOW YOU'VE GOT A PLACE YOU GOT
TO BE SO PLEASE COME HELP
PRESENT AND ONE. EIGHTY FIVE.
THE. WHEN YOU'RE READY GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I'D LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF UP
FOR THEIR THOROUGH EVALUATION
OF THIS LEGISLATION- ON THE
MEASURE BEFORE YOU MAKES A
NUMBER OF STRUCTURAL CHANGES-
TO HOW THIS OVERSEE LAMENTS
IT'S HOMELESS PROGRAMS AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE ESTABLISHES
THE OFFICE TO AND HOMELESS AS-
HOUSE IN THE GOVERNOR OFFICE.
THE OFFICE WILL BE OVERSEEN BY
A NEW SECRETARY AND HOUSING AND
SECURED IN HOME. NEW SECRETARY
BE IN CHARGE OVERSEE ALL STATE
RAMPS WE TO YOU TO AGE BY EXIST
ENTIT. OVER DECADES THE STATE
HAS ADDED MORE AND LAYERS OF
NEW POLICIES TO COMBAT THE
INCREASING HOMELESSNESS
EPIDEMIC THEY'RE CURRENTLY AT
LEAST THIRTEEN DIFFERENT STATE
AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS
ADMINISTERING OVER THIRTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RELATED. TO
HOMELESSNESS. ALL OF THIS IS
ALL WELL AND- THE PROCESS HAS
CREATED A SYSTEM THAT IS HIGHLY
FRAGMENTED OFTEN WITH COMPETING
GOALS THAT ULTIMATELY RESULT IN
A DISJOINTED RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS. THIS FRAGMENTATION HAS
BEEN TALKING IT OVER THE YEARS
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE THE-
GEN REC NINE ALL HOPELESS STATE
PROGRAMS TO BE HOUSED UNDER ONE
ENTITY. ALMOST THREE DECADES
LATER AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
REPORTED THE CORE REASON OUR
AND SHELTERED HOMELESS
POPULATION EXCEEDS THAT OF
OTHER STATES IS DUE TO THE FACT
THAT THE OTHER STATES HAVE A
SINGLE ENTITY CHART
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE DRESSING
HOMELESS. AS SIMPLY AS LAST
MONTH THE LA- COMMENTED ON THE
STATE'S CURRENT APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS BY
ASSERTING AND I QUOTE.
ADDRESSING A PROBLEM AS COMPLEX
AND INTERCONNECTED AS HOMELESS
THIS REQUIRES THE INVOLVEMENT
OF DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
ACROSS THE STATE COOPERATION.
WITH ALL LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT
AND OTHER. STAKEHOLDERS AND
QUOTE. THEY GO ON TO SAY A
FRAGMENTED RESPONSE CREATES
VARIOUS CHALLENGES INCLUDING
FACULTY TRACKING ALL
HOMELESSNESS RELATED
EXPENDITURES ACROSS THE STATE.
THE TERM AND HOW DOES WORK AB
LEE. AND ALSO DIFFICULT
ASSESSING WHAT PROGRAMS ARE
COLLECTIVELY PUBLISHED. I'M
KNOW THAT HOMELESSNESS THE
STATE WIDE CRISIS- THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS DEDICATED
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS WELL STATE FUNDING
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE. IN THE
FIGHT AGAINST HOMELESSNESS
FUNDING LOAN WILL NOT CALL
SYSTEMIC SHOES IT'S TIME WE
FIND DRESS ARE STRUCTURAL
ISSUES AT THE STATE LEVEL. SO
TODAY I HAVE I'M SURE REPORT
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE POLICY- FOR THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING AND CHRIS MARTIN SINGS
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR
HOUSING CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
MISTER PORTER MISTER. READING
CHAIRS A MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTOPHER MARTIN WITH HOUSING
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE PROUD
BECAUSE SPONSORS OF AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE HOUSING CALIFORNIA
IS A NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION WITH THE MISSION
TO ENSURE THAT NO ONE IS
HOMELESS AND EVERYONE
REGARDLESS OF INCOME THE SAFE
STABLE AND AFFORDABLE PLACE TO
LIVE. AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED
CALIFORNIA HAS FUNDED WELL OVER
TWENTY FIVE PROGRAMS RELATED
HOMELESSNESS AND A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND
AGENCIES EACH WITH DIFFERENT
GOAL AND POPULATION TARGETS AND
AS A RESULT ONE OF THE MOST
RESPONSES FROM PROVIDERS AND WE
SIT IN THE COMMUNITIES. I'D WAS
THAT ALMOST PRO LET. NATION
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS FILL MULTIPLE
APPLICATIONS REQUIRING
DIFFERENT CRITERIA AND
DEADLINES WITH NO CROSS AGENCY
OR COURT CROSS DEPARTMENTAL
COLLABORATION. AND PROGRAMS
OFTEN HAVE INCONSISTENT OFTEN
CONFLICTING REQUIREMENTS. MANY
OF THESE PROGRAMS ARE ALSO NOT
pINTERVENTIONS WHICH MEANS WE
ARE NOT ACTUALLY DECREASING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE AT
THE RATE AND I THINK OF HIS
ADVOCACY THAT WE COULD. AB
EIGHT FORTY FIVE WOULD CREATE A
NEW OFFICE WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHOSE CHIEF
GOAL WOULD BE TO COORDINATE
AMONG THE STATE AGENCIES AND
PROGRAMS TO BREAK DOWN SILOS
CREATED BY FUNDING MANY
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS. BRING
TO. THE AND KNOWLEDGE OF HOW
CONSERVE. THE STAFF TO OUR IN A
CORE SET OF STANDARDS FOR
HOUSING AND HOUSING BASED
SERVICES. FOLLOW EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS PROVENTO AND
HOMELESSNESS AND INSTITUTE
BACKS PRACTICES FOR PREVENTING
CALIFORNIANS FROM EXITING STATE
FUNDED INSTITUTIONAL SETTINGS
INTO HOMELESSNESS. THIS OFFICE
WILL STEP FORWARD A CLEAR FOCUS
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE'S PATH
TOWARDS ENDING HOMELESSNESS AND
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE HAS A
SAFE AFFORDABLE PLACE TO LIVE.
IS FOR INPUT FUNDING AND- HOME.
BEING AN EVIDENCE BASED
SOLUTIONS HOUSING CALIFORNIA
APPLAUD ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIVAS
FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS
ISSUE IS PROUD TO CUT A CO
SPONSOR AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
IDOL THANK YOU. THANK YOU THE
MORNING SURE FOR WITH
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT OF
HOUSING- I SERVED ON THE
GOVERNOR'S COUNCIL REGIONAL
HOMELESS ADVISORS WHICH MOST
PEOPLE PURCHASE THE GOVERNOR'S
TASK FORCE- AND CSA TO THE CODE.
ON A TEN FORTY FIVE. LONG
CALIFORNIA HAS LACKED A SINGLE
THE OVER THE ISSUE OF
HOMELESSNESS AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS STATED HOMELESSNESS IS A
COMPLEX CHALLENGE- TOUCHING
MANY DIFFERENT ISSUES EDUCATION
AND CHILD WELFARE OUR OUR
HEALTH CARE. CORRECTIONS AS
EXAMPLES- BUT WE'VE NEVER HAD A
SINGLE AGENCY OFFICE OR
INDIVIDUAL TO OVERSEE A SINGLE
COORDINATED CLAPPER. ON SINGLE
THAT LEAVE THE STATE'S ON
AUTHORITY AND HOMELESS S. AND
BIG BLUE LETTERS AND GOVERNOR.
COME IS IT. EXPECTED TO BE. THE
WHOLE THIS CALL THANKS OF ITS
THREE WE KNOW THAT'S ALL IT.
YEP BECAUSE WE HAVE NO IF MEN
OF OUR AGENCIES ADMINISTERING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE NOT BASED ON
EVIDENCE FOR THIS REASON TO
CRITICAL RECOMMENDATIONS COMING
FROM THE TASK FORCE. WERE TO
CREATE A SINGLE POINT OF
AUTHORITY AND- TO HAVE A
STANDARDIZED RESPONSE FROM OUR
ALL OF OUR PROGRAMS THAT ARE
CHARGED WITH ENDING HOMELESS.
UNDER EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE THE
SINGLE POINT OF AUTHORITY AS
SECRETARY WITHIN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WILL ENSURE PROGRAMS ARE
ACHIEVING THAT OUT. THE LETTER
TO THE GOVERNOR AND THE TAX
PAYER EXPECT. IT ALSO WOULD
STANDARDIZE THEIR STATE'S
RESPONSE TO THAT PROGRAMS ARE
FUNDING THE SAME TYPE OF
HOUSING AND HOUSING BASED
SERVICES INTERVENTIONS AND
EVENTUALLY BLENDING FUNDING
THAT COULD BE USED TO PAY FOR
HOUSING AND SERVICES. IS SIMPLY
WILL MAKE OUR SYSTEMS MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT AND
FOUND A SPREAD OF TAXPAYER
DOLLARS MORE WISELY. THE OFFICE
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
REGULARLY CONVENING STAFF AT
THE AGENCIES TO DO THE WORK OF
STANDARDIZING THE STATE'S BOND.
AND IF IT EVENTUALLY BURKE TO
CREATE A UNIVERSAL APPLICATION
OF WHAT OUR HOUSE AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS TWO BUY FOR STATE
FUNDING- WITHOUT NAVIGATING
CONFLICTING PROGRAM
REQUIREMENTS LIKE WE HAVE. I
APPRECIATE IT ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RIVAS LEADERSHIP AND TAKING ON
THIS BILL AND REQUEST DRIVE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LET
ME ASK IF THERE ARE OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL. THEN
ASH OVER THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE SHIRKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. AND IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. SEEN ON THE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. THIS
COURSE OF ACTUALLY BEFORE WE
PROCEED IF I COULD ESTABLISH
QUORUM MADAM SECRETARY. TO HEAR
TO HEAR TAPE. GABRIEL GLORIA
GLORIA HERE KILEY KILEY HERE
MON. MAIENSCHEIN MENTION HERE
QUIRK SILVA HERE LOOKS LIKE
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM IS QUIRK
SILVA- YES THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD INTO THE SPONSORS- AT.
ELITE B. SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
I KNOW WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
THIS LAST YEAR AS WE WERE
WORKING ON ONE OF OUR BILLS.
BUT AFTER ATTENDING A WEEK
HELPING POLICY. THERE ARE SO
MANY OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OUT IN THE POLICY
BE CA. OUT OF ALL MUCH MONEY DO
WE HAVE HOW'S IT BEEN WHAT ARE
THE GAS IN FOR ALL OF THESE AND
IF YOU'RE WORKING WITH TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY PARTNERS AND
EVERYBODY HAS A DIFFERENT
PRIORITY ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE GOOD INTENTIONS BUT WE HAVE
A VERY HARD TIME NAVIGATING AND
PARTICULARLY THE- ONCE THAT.
ULTIMATELY ARE EITHER GOING TO
BE APPLYING AND THE COUNTIES IN
HAVING TO IMPLEMENT SO HAVING
ONE- BASE FOR SOMEBODY TO
INTERACT I GUESS MY ONLY MAJOR
QUESTION WOULD BE. IF PASSED
HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET ALL OF
THESE AGENCIES TOGETHER AND-
NOT CREATE ANOTHER- IF YOU WANT
TO SAY- INSTITUTION- BECAUSE I
DON'T KNOW THAT WE WANT TO. WE
WANT TO HAVE A FOCUS BUT WE
WANT I WANT TO KEEP AT DOLLARS
INTO ADMINISTRATION WE WANT TO
GET THOSE DOLLARS OUT TO. THE
SHELL. OR FOR THAT BUILDING I
DON'T. KNOW I AM I THINK THAT
BIAS BY CREATING ONE OFFICE ONE
ESPECIALLY WITHIN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- IT WOULD
ACTUALLY UP STREAMLINE THE
DELIVERY OF SERVICES AND LIKE
LIKE I SAID EARLIER THEY'RE
CURRENTLY THIRTEEN DIFFERENT
AGENCIES THAT RUN THIRTY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS RIGHT AND- I
THINK WE- VALUE WAIT. THIS AND
I THINK THAT WOULD BE UP TO THE
SECRETARY ON THAT I'M PROPOSING.
OTHER COMMENTS MISTER GORE.
READING JUST COMMON APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WITH US FOR
OFFERING THIS LEGISLATION I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT STAFF ANALYSIS
THE LIVE EXPLAINS CLEARLY THAT
THE GOVERNOR COULD DO THAT
EIGHT DOLLARS OFF SWITCH IT ON
THEIR OWN I DON'T THINK IS A
WITH THE LEDGES. WE WOULD LIKE.
THIS BUT THAT IS THAT YOUR ON
THIS ISSUE FOR MANY YEARS WELL
THE PLACES WHERE WE'VE SEEN
TRANSFORMATIONAL CHANGE ON HOW.
STRONG EXACT YOUR SHIP A MATTER
OF REALLY BRINGING EVERYONE TO
GO THERE AND HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE ONLINE WHAT MICHAEL
WAS JUST TOO MANY MORE THAN. ON
THE TICKET RIGHT. PASSED LIKE
THE SITUATION. BECAUSE OF THE
CITY FUNDING GREATER ACCOUNT OF
TRANCE BY EXECUTIVE BRANCH I
THINK IS A STRATEGY HAS BEEN
USED SUCCESSFULLY IN CITIES
ACROSS THE NATION I'D LOVE TO
RIGHT HERE AT THE STATE AND
WEBER CALIFORNIA TO LEAVE
MATTER SO. THIS BILL IF I'M
HAPPY. WITH THE BILL. AND HOPE
RECEIPT SAYS A SUBJECT A XIN AS
RECOMMENDED AND IN MY WITH
THAT'S ACROSS NATION. YOU
MISTER LARA. MR GOOD MORNING SO
I WANTED LINES I MEAN THE
GOVERNOR SOME STATEMENT ALONG
THE LINES OF I AM THE HOMELESS
ARE FOR CALIFORNIA- SO DOES
KINDA JIVIN WITH THAT STATEMENT
I THINK THAT ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S DOT THAT'S BEEN
ENCOURAGING IS HE'S REALLY
TAKEN OWNERSHIP. THE ISSUE.
WELL SURE. COUNTY OKAY WE HAVE
A ALMOST NAY SO I IT'S NOT
REALLY OUR ISSUE ANYMORE YOU
KNOW GOVERNOR THEN HAS BEEN AN
IN HOMELESS YES AND I THINK
THAT. CONTRADICT HIS STATEMENT
I THINK I'M PART OF BEING A
LEADER IS THEN APPOINTEE AND
SOMEONE AT THE EXECUTIVE LEVEL.
TO OVERSEE THIS ISSUE. AND I
THINK IT WOULD MAKE IT A LOT
MORE IMPORTANT. I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR- YOUR ENGAGEMENT YOUR
DEEP ENGAGEMENT ON THIS- THIS
IS A TOPIC WE TALKED ABOUT FOR.
A NUMBER OF THE PROJECT OR WORK
WITH OUR STAFF. TO APPRECIATE
THE WORK OF AB IT'S HONEST. TO
SUPPORT IT UP. FOR I THINK THE
FACT IT. OF THIRD CHEN SEES
RUNNING A THIRTY PROGRAMS
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE AND
TO. MR ALI'S POINT. I'VE EVEN
FORGOTTEN. SELF THIS AS
PROMISES ARE I DO THINK THIS
KIND OF A BILL COULD PROVIDE
THE FRAZIER PARK A TO HELP HIM
PUSH ALL OF OUR- GOALS AND
OBJECTIVES. YOU KNOW FOR MY
PERSPECTIVE THERE ARE AT LEAST
THREE THINGS WE NEED TO MOVE
THINGS FOR WHEN IT COMES TO
HOMELESSNESS WHY THE FIGURE OUT.
MEDICAL FUND THE- WORKING WITH
SOME THE BILL TO SESUAI THAT.
THE GAP IS MOVING FORWARD.
SECONDLY I THINK AS MR GLORIA
SAID WE REALLY NEED TO ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND WE ARE DOING.
FORTY BEING DONE ON THAT FRONT.
IMPORTANTLY AS FAR IN ANY CASE
BUT HE IS FRANKLY STREAMLINING
WHAT WE'VE GOT AND I THINK THIS
BILL SQUARELY THIS IS THAT IN
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE TO ME SO
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE WORD. AND
THE LESS THERE ARE COMMON WOULD
LIKE TO ASK. I'M FOR THE
DISCUSSION TODAY. YOU KNOW AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE IS JUST
COMMON SENSE LIKE MANY OF YOU
HAVE SAID TO SAY. WE CAN'T CAN
YOU. OUT BID STRUCTURES- TO
THIS COMPLEX ISSUE THE HAS
GROWN IN RECENT YEARS- AND I
THINK IT'S TIME FOR SPEAK UP
AND- STRUCTURE IT IN A WAY
THAT. WILL BE MORE EFFECTIVE
AND WE WILL BE TO WORK BETTER
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THIS
CALL THIS- SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTIONS
TO PASSING REFERRED THE
COMEDIAN. TO SHOOT AYE. AYE THE
I GABRIELLE GLORIA GLORIA I
KILEY. KILEY NO LIMA LIMA I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK
SILVA QUIRK SILVA I. THE VOTE
IS SIX ONE YOUR MEASURES OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WHAT'S NOW PROCEED TO FILE ITEM
TO BE EIGHTEEN FIFTY SEVEN MR
CHEN. THANK YOU FOR SHARING
MEMBERS FOR YOUR TIME. I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN
TH DISTRICT BUILDING THAT WILL
HELP THE CITY UPPER RIVER IS
TAXPAYER DOLLARS BACK. PROGRAM
I JUST BY CLARIFYING THAT THIS
BILL IS DISTRICTS WAS. THE CITY
OF BREA INTO. THIS CAL. AND I.
NEED OF A SEPARATE. PARAMEDIC
OF ONE PAIR BRUCE'S IN THE CITY
THE INTENT OF THE TAG WAS TO
FOR A LOCAL MEDICAL. BUT WHEN.
WAS CREATED A PORTION OF THE
PARAMEDIC TAX WAS CAPTURED BY
THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY.
SAVERS IN OF TODAY. EIGHTEEN
FIFTY WILL RESTORE HARPER SAID
OF THE PARENTS TAX TO FUND THE-
PROGRAM. AND THEREBY FULLY IN
SUPPORT. THE OUTSTANDING
QUALIFICATIONS WOULD PAY FOR
FROM OTHER AVAILABLE TAX
REVENUE RESOURCE FROM THE CITY
OF BREA THEREFORE THE PARAMEDIC
TAX CAN BE ONLY IF THE PURPOSE
AND ENDED BY THE VOTERS.
PROGRAM THE EIGHTY WHEN IS A
RICHARD OF THE AND I WAS VETO
LAST YEAR BY COVER YOU SEND THE
GUMS MESSES SO JUST GO THROUGH
THE BUDGET PROCESS OF OUR
DOUBLE KING AB AT FIFTY AND
THIS YEAR WITH BUDGET TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE HERE WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IS CORTES AND RIVER
CITY. MORNING TO. IT BEFORE
IT'S YOU ABOUT AB AT PLEASE
ALLOW ME TO SHARE SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE CITY OF BREA
BREA IS A SMALL COMMUNITY LOOK
INSIDE CALIFORNIA I SOLD BUT
HELP NORTH COUNTY AND BORDERED
BY UNINCORPORATED AREN'T
BLESSING COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY ONE THE OLDEST
COMMUNITIES IN ORANGE COUNTY
BREA WHAT RATED AT NINETEEN
SAID. AS A THE HOP SQUARE MILE.
AND FIRE PROTECTION WATER IN
SENATE'S CHEN CONSTRUCTION
STREET MAINTENANCE RECREATION
HUMAN SERVICES IN CULTURAL
ARTS. AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MENTIONED IN SEVENTY EIGHT THE
CITY OF BREA APPROVED A
PARAMEDIC TAX BY 80% OF THEIR
VOTERS TO ESTABLISH FIND A
LOCAL PAY. PROGRAM IN THE- INTO
THE- DEVELOP. ALL BRANDS
INCREMENTAL PRO TAX INCLUDING
US A PORTION A PARAMEDIC TAX
WAS ALLOCATED TO PAY DOWN THE
DEBT SERVICE BONDS AND OTHER
OBLIGATIONS OF THE FORMER BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY THIS
HAPPENED BECAUSE WHEN THE CITY
ESTABLISHED READ ABOUT AGENCIES
NAY EIGHTY ONE THERE WAS GINNY
LED TO EXCLUDE SPECIAL TALK.
THOSE PATIENT ARE PAID MUCH OF
BACK TOP IS REVERTING BACK TO
THE CITY IS THE REDEVELOPMENT
AND THOSE ABA ARE COMPLETELY
PAY DOWN AND TWENTY THIRTY SIX
ALL OF THE PARAMEDICS SNAPPER
ACTED. REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY
COME BACK TO THE CITY HOWEVER
AND TOLD THAT TIME AND TWENTY
THREE SIX. GRAHAM IS BEING
SUBSIDIZED BY APPROXIMATELY ONE
AND A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL REVENUES THIS IS DUE IN
PART THE FACT THAT A PORTION
THE PARAMEDIC TAXES ARE BEING
OUT. PAID DEBT SERVICE. CHEN C.
THE CITY HAS. THAT'S STAND READ
ABOUT BOB. CAN BE PAID FROM OUR
AVAIL TAX INCREMENTS REVENUE
SPUR SAYS AND THE PARAMEDIC TAX
IS NOT NEEDED FOR THAT. PURPOSE
I WOULD SAY IS THAT THE CITY OF
BREA WILL CONTINUE TO PAY ITS
FULL THAT SIR ON REDEVELOPMENT.
AND THAT. AM I FOR YOUR CAN.
AND RESPECT FOR OCT FOR YEARS
PART. YOUR A MEMBER COMMITTEE
CHRISTY WILL BE A OF THE
CALIFORNIA FIREFIGHTERS VERY
PLEASED TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. WE HAVE BEEN SHY ABOUT
OUR POSITION ON ELEMENT FROM
THAT IT INFLICTED UPON GENERAL
FUND UP AND DOWN. A CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS WHY WE TOOK PRETTY
STRONG POSITION WHEN THOSE IT
SEES A WHILE DOWN. APPROPRIATE
THE CITY OF BRIGHT. A PROGRAM
IS LOCALLY WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS OF THE BILL. ANY
OPPOSITION DON'T. BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS. HAS
BEEN MOTIONS ARE SECOND. SECOND
ANY COMMENTS MR CAN I HAVE ONE
COMMENT IN A QUESTION SO HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL I
SUPPORTED LAST YOU'RE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS. OBVIOUSLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S VETO LETTER. I
REFERENCE THE FACT THAT THERE
WERE NOT MONIES TO BACK FILL
HE'S MADE IT CLEAR HE'S NOT%
INTERESTED IN MOVING FOR WITH
REDEVELOPING AGAIN THIS YEAR I
KNOW YOU GOT A BUDGET ASK WHAT
HAPPENED IF. THIS DOESN'T
HAPPEN. WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THIS.
AS I UNDERSTAND. HOW MANY OF
THE REGIONAL AND PROJECTS- AND
BELGIAN ASKED THAT WERE DONE IN
THE PREVIOUS YEAR WERE. VETOED
BY. WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO MONEY
ADDITIONAL TO FIND A MESSAGE IN
THE CITY TO TRY TO FIND TO MAKE
THIS WHOLE BUT UNTIL THIS BILL
WAS PASSED ON THIS. PROGRAM WE
CANNOT BE. GOT IT. AS A PERSON
WHO CARRYING THREE THE- VEHICLE
TO MOVE FOR WITH AND COVERS.
WE'RE WELL AWARE THE FACT THE
GOVERNOR AT THIS MOMENT IS NOT
WILLING TO MOVE THESE IDEAS
FORD BUT WISH YOU ALL THE BEST
AS YOU. MOVE THERE BUT QUESTION.
ARE GIVEN COMMENTS AGAIN THANK
YOU MISTER FOR TOP. THANK YOUR
STAFF THE OUTSTANDING IN TERM
OF THEIR HELP ON THIS
PARTICULAR BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
MADAM SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS
THIRTY THE COMEDIAN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TWO FIVE TWO I DATE
HI I GABRIEL GLORIA. GLORIA I
KILEY KILEY AYE LEE MON LIMóN
NINE MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
NIGHT QUIRK SILVA THANKS BYE.
THE MEASURE IS UNANIMOUS. YOUR
MEASURES OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET
US CALL IT FILE ITEM FOR HER AB
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN MISTER
HIS AREA. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. AB NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION TO ASSEMBLE A
WORKING GROUP CONSISTING OF
VARIOUS BUILDING HOUSING AN
ENGINEERING EXPERT TO REVIEW
NEW POST BUILD PERFORMANCE.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF ESSENTIAL
FACILITIES SUCH AS HOSPITALS
SCHOOLS AND FIRE STATION THE
CURRENT BUILDING CODE IS ONLY
DESIGNED TO ACT AGAINST OF LOVE
YOUR KIDS. THE CODES NOTHING
ABOUT WHETHER OR WHEN A
BUILDING WILL BE USABLE AFTER A
LARGE SEISMIC EVENT EVEN NEW
BUILDINGS ARE EXPECTED TO HAVE
SIGNIFICANT REPAIR COSTS AND
DOWNTIME AFTER MAJOR.
CALIFORNIA EARTHQUAKE GIVING
CALVET CURRENT APPROACH TO
BUILDING STANDARDS A MAJOR
EARTHQUAKE WOULD CAUSE MASS
DISPLACEMENT AND SIGNIFICANT
TRACTION TO THE REGIONAL
ECONOMY. A. B. THE NINETY SEVEN
MERE THAT FOR CALIFORNIA THE-
ASSESS WHETHER IT IS TIME FOR
THE STATE TO CONSIDER CHANGING
OUR APPROACH TO BUILDING
STANDARDS. FUNCTIONAL COVERAGE
STANDARD- I WOULD JUST ADD THAT
HAVE BEEN WITH OPPOSITION
BEFORE HEARING I AM WILLING TO
INCLUDE THE INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF PLUMBING AND
LOCAL OFFICIALS. AND THE
NATIONAL FIRE PROTECTION
ASSOCIATION THE END IS LISTED
IN THE WORK GROUP AS AN
AMENDMENT. CHAU ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE
OPPORTUNITY DISCUSS THE
IMPORTANCE OF AB NINETEEN
NINETY SEVEN I'M RYAN CURSING
AT PRACTICING STRUCTURES YEAR
HERE IN SACRAMENTO SPEAKING
TODAY ON BEHALF OF OVER THIRTY
FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS OF THE
STRUCTURAL ENGINEERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA OR
THE OCT WE ARE THE EXPERTS WHEN
IT COMES UNDERSTANDING THE
PERFORMANCE OF OUR BUILDING IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE THIS BOND
THIS GIVEN VERY NOT THIS WILL
DO IT TO REITERATE IF YOU
DETAILS AND POINT OUT OF POINTS
FIRST FUNCTIONS YEARS NOW ARE
CO WITH FOLKS I SAFETY WE DON'T
HE AT THAT THERE'D IMAGE WILL
BE LIMITED OR THAT CONTINUE
OPERATION PROVIDE. RECENT
STUDIES SHOW THAT MOST NEW
BUILDINGS WILL SUFFER MANY
WEEKS IF NOT MONTHS OF DOWNTIME
TO REPAIR THAT CAUGHT DAMAGE
ACTIVE FOR. IN BETTER AND I
WOULD EXPECT YOU WOULD EXPECT
SOMETHING BETTER THAT SECOND
THE BILL DOES NOT MANDATE AN
IMMEDIATE CHANGE NOR A ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH BUT RATHER
JUST INITIATES THE PROCESS FOR
STATE ORDERS HAVE RECESSION TO
DISCUSS WE MIGHT BETTER PROTECT.
THIRD THE ACTIVITIES WILL BE
INFORMED BY AND COMPLIMENTS
EFFORTS HAPPEN AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL WERE NOT DUPLICATING
EFFORTS. SIAC IS ENGAGE IN
THOSE FEDERAL EFFORTS- BY THE
NY HER AGENCIES HAVE BEEN
CHARGED WITH WRITING REPORT TO
CONGRESS AND OUR NEED TO NEARLY
COMPLETE WITH THAT REPORT I'M
ACTUALLY CHIU. OF THE THAT'S
RIGHT IN THAT REPORTS. I'M HERE
JUST LIKE THE ASCII. ALTHOUGH I
CAN PROVIDE CA. OR ANSWERS
THE QUESTIONS IF YOU LIKE ABOUT
THE REPORT. THE WORKING GROUP
WILL BE FORM SHORTLY AFTER THE
REPORTS ISSUE TO CONGRESS- THE
RIVER WAS EXPECTED CAN OPTIONS
FOR FULL CONSIDERATION STATE
AND LOCAL ELECTIONS. UNTIL BY
THE TIME THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
MIGHT CHOOSE OR MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO IT MORE. THE WORKING GROUP
CAN DISCUSS OUR IF THESE ARE MY
APPLY TO CALIFORNIA AND WHAT WE
MIGHT BE DOING IN NEXT STEPS
HERE FOR OUR STATE AND OUR
UNIQUE SEISMIC RISK. FINAL KNOW
THEIR OWN EFFORTS STATE LAW TO
PARKING IS MORE EASILY. POSE
BUT I'D SAY. IN THE- MY MATCH.
AND THE TRICK. CONVERSATION IS
A COMPANION TO THOSE EFFORTS.
SO WE CONSIDER WORKING BECOME
RESILIENT TO THE EFFECTS OF
EARTHQUAKE WE ARE PROUD TO BE
THE SPONSOR THIS AND WE- FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. I GET ON THEIR
OTHERS OF THE BILL. GOOD
MORNING KATIE ALLMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING OFFICIALS
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL. SEVEN
NUMBER ARE THE PRINCIPAL DANGLE
ENGINEERS WAS FOR THIS BILL.
BOB BREMER'S SENIOR ENGINEER
WITH THE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND WHILE WE HAVE A
NEUTRAL POSITION- THE CURRENT
VERSION OF THIS BILL CONTAINS
AMENDMENTS THAT ALLOWED US TO
REMOVE OR OPPOSITION PREVIOUS
YEARS WE WERE WORKING WITH THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMITTEE ON
THIS THANK YOU. THANK YOU AT
THE PUBLIC AND INTO THE BILL OR
TWEETERS. SEEN ON LET'S BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS. I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR I KNOW THIS IS THE THIRD
TIME YOU MOVE THIS BILL HOPING
THIRD TIME'S A CHARM- THIS IS A
BILL THAT WE HAVE SUPPORTED
HEARINGS COMMITTEE- INOTES.
OBVIOUSLY FOR SOME MAKERS WE
FOCUS ON THE IMMEDIATE CRISES
AT HALF OF HOMELESSNESS IN
CORONA VIRUS BUT- YOU TRY TO.
CALL THE LONG TERM CHALLENGE
THAT WE KNOW WILL BE A CRISIS
AND THAT IS AROUND. EARTHQUAKE
PREPAREDNESS I AND WITHOUT I'M-
HOPING WE CAN MOVE IT OUT AND
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST AS YOU
MOVE THROUGH THE PROCESS. YEAH
THERE'S BEEN A- SECOND ANY
FINAL COMMENTS. MISTER MISTER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND ALWAYS
WORKING WITH OUR STAFF. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WITH THAT MADAM
SECRETARY. MOTION TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS TO. I GAVE HI. I
GABRIEL GLORIA. GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY BAILEY MON. I NINE HI
MAIENSCHEIN AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I RIGHT SEVEN ZERO
YOUR BILL IS OUT AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BEST WISHES. WHEN
WE BRING UP OUR ITEM FILE ITEM
FIVE AB TWENTY FORTY FOUR
MISTER VOEPEL ANALYZE A SURGEON
TO CALL THE FINE. BILL MR CELLS
AS OFFICE DESK MAJORITY THANK
YOU. MR REBEL COLLEAGUES I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE- COMMITTEE
AND STAFF FOR ALL THEIR HELP ON
AB TWENTY FORTY FOUR- I'D LIKE
TO START FIRST ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS PROPOSED BY THE
COMMITTEE AND WILL SPEAK ON THE
AMENDED BILL VERY SHORTLY- I'D
ALSO LIKE TO INTRODUCE ROBERT
REMEMBER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE AB
TWENTY FORTY FOUR AS AMENDED
DEFINITION OF. EGGS HE- NEEDS
IT WAS RATHER THAN OF A NEW ONE
EIGHTY USER BASICALLY GRANNY
FLATS AND THE PURPOSE OF THIS
IS WHY PUT PHOTOVOLTAIC SOLAR
PANELS ON VERY SMALL GRANNY
FLATS THAT THAT WAS THE WHOLE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL- LASTLY
THE AMENDMENTS WILL REMOVE THE
MANDATE TO AMEND THE BUILDING
CODE TWO X. EIGHT IS A PHOTO
VOTE I REQUIREMENTS AND INSTEAD
RECALL TELL. ENERGY XIN DOES
ISSUE OLDER SYSTEMS DETACHED
EIGHTY YOU DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT TO PROPOSE CHANGES FOR
ADOPTION AND APPROVAL BY THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT MEDI SEND THIS TO
THOSE TWO COMMISSIONS THANK YOU
THANK YOU AWARENESS THANK YOU
MISTER MEMBERS BOB ROEMER YOUR
WITH THE BILL MR SO ASIAN AND
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL I IT IS RATE IS I CHOOSE
THAT WERE ARE IN DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION.
YOUR OTHER PUTTING IN EIGHTY
YOU ON THE INSIDE OF THE HOUSE
OR IF YOU'RE ATTACHING IT A TO
THE REAR WALL IT'S EXAM IN
ADDITION- IF YOU'RE TAKING AN
EXISTING STRUCTURE ON THE LOT
SUCH AS RAJ AND TURNING IT INTO
AN EIGHTY YOU THAT- WHO IS
EXEMPT ARE THE ISSUE IS BUT HOW
YOU HAVE THAT WAS UNIT THAT'S
UP THAT SPUR BASICALLY HAVE A
SMALL- US OUR REGION FROM THE
ORIGINAL UNIT AND SOME UNIT THE-
BETTER THAT. HOWEVER IS IN
SHAPE IN MANY IS IF YOU'RE
PUTTING THIS IN A TWO STORY I A
WILL PROBABLY THAT EXEMPTION
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY- THE CC
ADMINISTRATIVE RAKES INCLUDES
AN EXAM NGUYEN SOUL IS NOT COST
EFFECTIVE ALL OF THEIR
BUILDINGS AFTER THE FACT WELL I
IN ROUTE LEVY ARE. APPROACH THE
COMMISSION. RECALL RECEIVED A
AN EXEMPTION ARE SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE COST OF ELECTRICITY IN
TRINITY COUNTY IS ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THAT THAT WAS ASSUME
BY THE SEA CITY THE IT THAT
WERE IN OVER THE CALL AND
HOPEFULLY HAVE THE RESULT.
CERTAIN CAN BOB TO GO THROUGH
THAT'D MINISTRY PROCESS IT CAN
TAKE FOUR TO FIVE MONTHS AND WE
COULD BE POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT
HUNDREDS IF NOT THOUSANDS OF A
THAT WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH A
VERY ALL PROP SET THE TO COMMIT.
AND SO WHAT IS WORKING WITH CAL
AND THE DID YOU COMMISSION
STAFF AND OUT. VOTERS TO THE
EGGS RIGHT AND ADMINISTRATIVE
PROVISIONS. ALLOW OFFER THIS
EXEMPTION LAW AND IF THERE IS A
CAN WE JUST COME UP A FEW DO'S
AND DON'TS AND IF. PARAMETERS
ARE THE LOCAL LEVEL THE
BUILDING OFFICIAL. THE GRANT
EXEMPTION SO WHAT WE'RE WE'RE
WORKING ON THIS AND WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO GET THIS DONE BEFORE
SOME. IF YOU. IF THERE ARE
BORDERS OF THE BILL. TWITTER'S.
THANK YOU TURN NUMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
WIENER POSSESSION ENERGY SEE
HOW FOR YEARS NOW SO DEAD
LEGISLATION THAT DOES FROM THIS
BODY. AS AN EASE RESTRICTIONS
TO THE WIDESPREAD DEVELOPMENT
OF EIGHTY USE WE COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THAT
EIGHTY USE OUR SMART AND A
SMART GROWTH TOOL TO HELP WITH
THE STATE'S WORSENING HOUSE.
THIS WHEN IT COMES TO HELPING
AN INCREASING HOUSING FOR THE-
BUILDING CODE IN. FIRE MEN'S TO
DO JUST THAT WHICH IS A
CONSUMERS UNDER HEATING COOLING
AND BILL I'M IMPROVE THEIR
INDOOR AIR QUALITY IN THE
PROCESS. OF BLANKETING PRESTER
UTILITY. THAT BEING SAID WE
APPRECIATE COMMITTEES. ALL
THERE'D APPRECIATE BE AYE AS
WORK ON THIS ISSUE- SO WOULD BE
HAPPY TO RECONSIDER MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU. MORE IN
COMMON. CALIFORNIA I JUST WANT
TO ECHO ALL THE CONCERNS AND
COMMENTS RAISED BY A AND R. C.
AND CONSIDERING THE AMENDMENTS
WILL TAKE IT THERE ARE INTERNAL
PROCESS SINCE ABOUT UPDATE OUR
POSITION. YOU ARE BRING IT BACK
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT
OUR STAFF AND ALSO APPRECIATE
YOU ACCEPTING THE MOMENTS TO
NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR. THIS
BILL. BEING NUMBER WHAT. IT
WOULD NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE
BILL SIMPLY TO THE SOLAR
MANDATE AND NOT TO OTHER.
ASPECTS OF RG EFFICIENT SUCH.
SECONDLY IT REQUIRES THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO CONSIDER OF THE
BENEFITS OF RELIEVING EIGHTY IS
FROM THIS MAN I WEIGH THE
COSTS. AND ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
TAKING AMENDMENTS TO RISK.
CURRENT PROCESS. BUILDING
STANDARDS AND WITH AS A MATTER
SEND MY- DOUBLE A THIS FORD AND-
OUR- ON THIS. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. THERE'S BEEN A MOTION
WITH THE BILL AND A QUESTION BY
MISTER GORE. JUST A QUICK
COMMENT SO I WANT TO REITERATE
WHAT I HEARD IS THAT- THERE ARE
EXIST EFFORTS TO HAVE
EXEMPTIONS AND INSENSITIVITY TO
THE DIVERSE NATURE OF EIGHTY
USE SO THAT- JT NOTED. WERE
PART OF YOUR TEST. THESE ARE
ALREADY THE CASE THAT WILL
FURTHER CONSIDER- THE- SINCE
DENOUNCED THE GUESS IN A WAY NY
RATE. NUMBER ONE MANY OF THESE
LADIES ARE QUITE SMALL AND-
FRANKLY THE MAIN. WE CONSIDER
OUR TO DO SO OR- BUT THERE ARE
INSTANCES AN THERE'S ONE NOT
AROUND. HOUSE WHERE THEY. WITH
MY CONCERN WITH INITIAL WAS.
QUITE HONESTLY AT THE YOU CAN
DO. THE LOAD I THINK THAT IT
ACTUALLY A SUBJECT. AN INCREASE
IN IN FOR NOW SO OF MISTER
POPPY **** YOU MAY BE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS IN ORDER TO
ALLOW FOR MORE THAT
SOPHISTICATION. AND FURTHER
IT'S ALREADY BEING DONE- BY BY
STATE FOLK- BOTH AGAIN DE FISH
CAN TO YOUR STAFF. AS CHAIRMAN
FOR MAKING THAT POSSIBLE IN
ONE. AND SENSITIVITY TO THE DID
THE EIGHTY USE IS ALREADY BEING
DONE THIS BILL WILL ONLY
FURTHER THAT. THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA SECOND OF THE BILL. ANY
FINAL COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. MR REPEL ANY FINAL
COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GREAT- MADAM SECRETARY. MISSION
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
THE COMEDIAN NATURAL RESOURCES
TWO BY TWO I GAVE. I GABRIEL
GLORIA. GLORIA I KILEY KILEY
IDLY MON. NEWMAN AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN NIGHT
QUIRK SILVA QUIRK SILVA. THE
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO YOUR BILL IS
OUT THERE THANK YOU. AND FINAL
OF THE DAY MISTER SALAS FILE
ITEM THREE A. B. TWENTY THREE
WELCOME. THANK YOU IS SURE
THANK YOU MEMBERS I THINK FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN TWENTY THREE. FOR
A START OFF BY SAYING EXCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT
PRECIADO YOUR STAFF WORK ON
THAT. AS WELL- THE STILLS THIS
WILL ALLOW THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT THE SIZE
OF A GAS SHUT UP VICE. PROPOSES
BUILDING STE. ADOPT WILL PROVE
SAFETY RESIDENTS AN EARTHQUAKE
AS YOU MAY REMEMBER YEAR THERE
WAS ARE QUAKING KERN COUNTY- IN
FACT JUST BEFORE LAST WE JUST
HAD ONE OFF COSTA RICA SO IS
SOMETHING I THINK IS VERY TOUGH
THE SOMETHING THAT'LL PROTECT.
OUR RESIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
A LOT OF TIMES WILL NOT EXAMPLE
A LOT OF THE DAMAGES BECAUSE OF
NATURAL GAS. PIPELINE YOU SEE
THE FIRST RESPONDERS ACTUALLY
GOING TO THESE FIRES ALL THIS
DAMAGE THAT'S HAPPENING. I WILL
TALK TO THE FIRST RESPONDERS
LOT OF MR SAYING THEY'RE CAUGHT
UP A DEALING WITH THESE FIRES.
EVACUATING ONE ALL. OF AND THE
SUCH SO WITH THAT WE LIVE UP.
INDEED OUR WE'VE REVIEWED THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND- ONCE
WAS GOING TO THE BILL WILL BE
MOVING TO SUPPORT- EIGHT CD.
THIS ISSUE. FROM AS A RESULT OF
ANOTHER BILL BACK IN THE EARLY
TWO THOUSANDS. OF THE COUPLE
PROP. WITH TWO YEARS AGO. AND
THERE'S A CHANCE THE
MANUFACTURE. WE'RE FINE WITH
THAT PROCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OTHER SUPPORTERS GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SO CAL GAS WE DO
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT A LETTER IN
ONTO WE ARE HERE. I SUPPORTIVE
A POLICY TAKEN IN HAND. I'M SAY
IT. IS AND WE ATE WITH. THREE
THANK. THANK YOU. BILL IN A
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE IT'S-
MOTION WITH THE BILL MOTION
SECONDED BILL. YOURSELVES
APPRECIATE. OTHERS A QUESTION
I'M SORRY MISS BELLY WITH YOUR
QUESTION. IS THERE SOME THAT
THE COMMISSION ISN'T DOING THIS
ON ITS OWN WHY THEY NEED US TO.
MOVE THE SALT. ALL THEY WISH
GOV WOULD WELL MOVE EFFICIENTLY
BUT SOMETIMES IT TAKES NEED TO
MATCH FROM THE LEGISLATURE. AND
SO THIS BILL- ACTUALLY MATCH
THE COMMISSION ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THIS IN THE WAY THAT WE THINK
THEY SHOULD. ESPECIALLY IN THE
SENSE. CURRENT DOWN CALIPH.
OKAY DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY AS-
YOU A LARGER ONE OBVIOUSLY WHAT
HAPPENED OUT DOWN COUNTY AS
WELL. BUT WILL WANT TO DO IS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
PUTTING THAT. THING TO THAT
SPOT. THE LAST TIME THEY LOOKED
AT THE- DECADES. IS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE OF
EARTHQUAKES ACTUALLY ADOPTED
THIS LOCALLY SO. THE ISSUE THAT
THEY IDENTIFIED DECADES AGO.
LIKE LIKE I SAID I WAS CVA WAS
YOU KNOW THE TECHNOLOGIES
IMPROVE SINCE THEN AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
TAKE THE STANDARD INTO ACCOUNT.
ANY FINAL COMMENTS MISTER
KILEY. OKAY IS THERE A SECOND
BILL. I WILL SECOND IT- ONE I
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
TOPIC I THINK- SOMEONE WHO
REPRESENTS A VERY EARTHQUAKE
PRONE CITY- APPRECIATED BUT I
KNOW THAT IS THE CASE FOR
ALMOST ALL OF US IN THIS ROOM I
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR WORK WITH
THE A AND R. STAFF THAT- MR
COLLEGE POINT FIVE. GREW UP
EARLY VIGOROUS SUCH FOR THEM
TO- TO BOARD WITH THIS- AND
ALSO APPRECIATE WORKING SOME
THROUGH SOME OF THE TECHNICAL
ISSUES HERE HAPPY TO SUPPORT
MOVING FOR WITH ADMITS AND LAST
YEAR COMMENTS I APPRECIATE THE
THANK YOU Q. AND OBSERVER.
PASSES IN N REFERRED THE END
OF HER SHE TO HI. I GAVE HI I
GABRIELLE GLOW. GLORIA I. KILEY
NOT MORNING LEMOND LIMóN I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I QUIRK
SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I YOUR BILLS
OUT THANK YOU FOR SIX ZERO AND-
WITHOUT THAT IS THE END OF THE
AGENDA I THINK WE MAY HAVE ONE
OR TWO OUT ON SO AS WELL. YES
KIM THIS MEMBERS WANT TO ADD ON
TO ANYTHING. ONE IS VOTED AND-
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.